punishment changes Behavior faster
reward changes Behavior longer it just
takes longer to work if someone calls me
Alex and I don't like that and I slap
them and I say never call me that again
I might change their behavior really
quickly if I leave the room they might
say I was talking to Alex because I'm
not there to punish them and so
punishment only works as long as the
source of punishment is there and the
person doesn't get accustomed to the
punishment if you're always mean and
yell at all of your employees eventually
they stop carrying so you have to
increase the level of your threats you
increase the intensity and the variety
of how you claim to punish them